today we finally find out if the six
thousand dollar price tag for the Mac
Studio Ultra is actually worth it for
Architects until now archicad has been
running primarily on Rosetta 2 using the
old Intel software not actually using
the full capabilities however archicad
26 has come to the party with their
technology preview so that we can
actually test this software out against
Apple silicon and see how much of an
improvement this genuinely is over
everything we've seen in the past we're
going to be looking at template load
times export times render times and of
course overall archicad performance if
you pay close tension throughout this
video there is an Easter egg for all of
you arcad users out there starting with
the basic template load times we're
going to find two vastly different
results the Intel version managed to
load in 13.71 seconds which is
incredibly fast especially if you're
comparing it to an older PC whereas when
you step up to Apple's silicon's version
of arcad 26 that same template loads in
7.62 seconds that's 1.8 times faster by
simply going to the Apple silicon
dedicated version of archicad when
you're running an apple silicon chip now
if you're running a larger commercial
template that takes a lot longer to load
then you're again going to be quite
satisfied with these results the Intel
version of our cat 26 loads a large
commercial template in 17.21 seconds
whilst the Apple silicon loads it in
9.69 seconds again we see that
significant Improvement of 1.8 times
quicker load times in both templates
straight away now alongside icad 26
technology preview graphisoft actually
did a blog post that showcased their
predicted speed improvements and I'll
post them on the screen here they were
phenomenally faster at the start I
didn't actually believe any of these
speeds would be coming true however as
we started testing the standard load
times it became very quickly obvious
that what graphisoft is actually saying
might be true something that I thought
would become unstuck in this actual
Theory would be a PDF export time
Trading additionally this is primarily
focused on the read and write speeds of
your hard drive they don't have too much
to do with the actual software at least
that's what I thought and I was
completely wrong the Intel version of
RCA 26 manages to export 19 pages of
highly detailed documentation in 26
seconds whereas the Apple silicon
version does it in under 16 seconds
we're talking a 1.6 Improvement on read
write speeds typically that is never
improved at least in my experience and
now they've managed to do this as well
now I did promise an Easter egg to all
of the arcad users out there and for
those of you have been following me for
a while now you'll know that I love my
archicad shortcuts so what you're going
to see behind me is the full production
version of the arcad shortcuts desk mat
it is available right now on the website
so if you check out the description down
below it will be the first link down
there and you can purchase yourself an
archad shortcuts desk mat that will sit
on your table all the time and you're
never going gonna forget some of the
best shortcuts that'll save you so much
more time than the Apple silicon upgrade
can now if you saw my last video six
months ago when the Mac Studio Ultra was
delivered you saw that I compared it to
a PC and compared 3D wireframe Marquees
now I was very impressed with the speed
of the Intel version on the Mac the
Intel version manages to take a floor
plan cut it into a section of 3D and
turn it to a wireframe in 1.35 seconds
whereas when you convert to Apple
silicon it does it instantly there is
actually no load time whatsoever there
is no lag now this wasn't expected
straight away from this apple silicon I
did see similar results in the Intel
version because one second is basically
like zero lag but this now running on
Apple silicon's dedicated software and
chipset is truly no lag however we do
find ourselves with a fork in the road
and this is where Apple silicon's
version of arcade 26 just falls through
the floor we took a very base basic 800
by 600 pixel render and rendered it on
both softwares the Intel version managed
to do it in just 19 seconds again it was
a very very basic render it wasn't
expected to take a long time the Apple
silicon render took 37 seconds so for
some reason Apple silicon's arcade 26
does it in twice as long there is no
justifiable answer here the quality is
approximately the same so what will
hopefully happen when the full arcad 26
release version of the Apple silicon
dedicated software comes out is that
they will fix this glitch they will fix
this problem and it will eventually get
better however when that time comes
we're going to have to test it again
because at this current point in time if
you're doing a lot of renders and you
need render times stay with the Intel
version don't move across to the Apple
silicon version that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed the video make sure you
check out the playlist to the side of me
for more great architectural and
archicad content if you love The video
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below leave a comment and of
course hit the like button too but like
always I'll see you next Monday